-Guys, today is Friday
and that's usually
when I catch up on some personal
stuff, you know.
I check my inbox,
I return some emails,
and, of course,
I send out thank you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And I was running --
running a bit behind today,
so, I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out my weekly
thank you notes right now.
Is that okay with you?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Appreciate it.
James, can I get
some thank you note writing
music, please?
-[ Playing tender tune ]
-Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
-Ooh!
-[Indistinct]
-Hm.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Ron DeSantis'
ongoing feud with Disney World,
for making even parents say,
"Let it go!"
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, weed gummies,
for coming in two varieties --
barely feel it
or enter the 11th dimension.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-[ Warbling ]
[ Warbling ] Jimmy.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you,
"Super Mario Bros," movie,
for being expected to make
a billion dollars.
Or, in Mario terms...
[ Chiming ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Earth Day,
for sounding like someone
suppressing a burp
while saying the word birthday.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Earth Day.
Happy Earth Day.
-Earth Day.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, SpaceX Starship...
-Aw.
-...for being a failed
rocket launch,
but a super successful
fireworks launch.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Aah! Ooh!
-Ooh, ah ooh, ah.
That's my favorite. Ooh, ah.
-[ Scat singing Fucik's
"Entrance of the Gladiators" ]
-No, that one's my favorite.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, artists,
for creating the world's
most beautiful music, paintings,
and Subway sandwiches.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, alarm clocks,
for wearing
noise canceling headphones.
Oh, there you have it,
everybody,
those are our "Thank You Notes."